>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> SPEAKER: GOOD EVENING.
WELCOME TO THE KLUGE AUDITORIUM
AT LIBRARY OF CONGRESS.
I'M NICHOLAS BROWN, ONE OF THE
AUTHORS OF BIBLIODISCOTHEQUE.
WE ARE THRILLED TO
HAVE YOU THIS EVENING
ON TIM GUNN ON DISCO FASHION.
IT'S BEING BROAD CASTED LIVE
ON FACEBOOK AND YOUTUBE.
THE LIBRARY'S DISCO SERIES IS
AN EXPLORATION OF DISCO DANCE,
MUSIC AND CULTURE IN THE LIBRARY.
POPULAR CULTURE IS RICHLY
COLLECTED IN THE LIBRARY'S DEPOSIT
OF HIT SONGS, SHEET
MUSIC, AUDIO RECORDINGS,
MANUSCRIPT AND FEATURE FILMS.
WE ARE PRIVILEGED TO BE
JOINED THROUGHOUT THE WEEK
BY LEADING SCHOLARS, EXPERTS AND
PERFORMERS FOR DISCO DEVELOPMENT,
LEGACY AND A CULTURAL PHENOMENON.
AS YOU PARTICIPATE
IN BIBLIODISCOTHEQUE,
WE INVITE YOU TO PARTICIPATE
ONLINE HASHTAG LC DISCO.
BE SURE TO VISIT OUR BE
DAZZLED DISCO BALL IN FRONT
OF THE THOMAS JEFFERSON
BUILDING TO GRAB A PHOTO.
THIS PROGRAM AND ALL OF THE
BIBLIODISCOTHEQUE EVENTS ARE MADE
THROUGH SUPPORT OF THE
LIBRARY OF CONGRESS.
AS YOU SPEND YOUR TIME HERE TONIGHT,
WE INVITE YOU TO MAKE A
DONATION VIA LOC.GOV/DISCO.
IT'S MY PRIVILEGE TO INTRODUCE
OUR SPEAKERS THIS EVENING.
ROBERT NEWLEN WHO WILL INTRODUCE
MR. GUNN IS THE DEPUTY LIBRARIAN
OF CONGRESS.
HE HAS SERVED AT THE LIBRARY SINCE
1975 INCLUDING CHIEF OF STAFF,
DEPUTY LAW LIBRARIAN, ASSISTANCE
KNOWLEDGE SERVICES GROUP
AND DIRECTOR OF RESEARCH SERVICE AND
CRS LEGISLATIVE RELATIONS OFFICE.
HOLDS DEGREES FROM AMERICAN
UNIVERSITY, CATHOLIC UNIVERSITY
IN AMERICA AND BRIDGE WATER COLLEGE.
SERVED ON THE BOARD OF
AMERICAN LIBRARY ASSOCIATION.
TIM GUNN IS A FASHION HOST
ON EMMY PROJECT RUNWAY.
HE HAS HAD STINTS INCLUDING
LIZ CLAREBORN OPERATED, PACIFIC
AND CHAIR OF FASHION DESIGN
AT PARSONS SCHOOL OF DESIGN.
ALSO AS A DISTINGUISHED WRITER,
GUNN HAS SOLD BEST SELLING BOOKS
AND KATHY MCDROTAL PUT
TOGETHER A DISPLAY THIS EVENING
AND YOU CAN SEE MR.
GUNN'S WORK IN THE LOBBY.
MR. GUNN HAS WRITTEN FOR ELLE,
PEOPLE AND NEW YORK MAGAZINE
AND WRITTEN FOR NEW
YORK TIMES, MARIE CLAIRE
AND ENTERTAINMENT WEEKLY.
IMMEDIATELY FOLLOWING TONIGHT'S
INTERVIEW, MR. GUNN WILL SIGN
AT THE PAVILION WHICH IS ON TOP OF
THE AUDITORIUM RIGHT UP THE STAIRS.
AUDIENCE, PLEASE WELCOME
ROBERT NEWLEN AND TIM GUNN.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE].
THANK YOU.
>> SPEAKER: WELL THANK YOU FOR WOW.
>> SPEAKER: WELL THANK
YOU FOR BEING HERE.
OKAY. IT'S TIME TO GO.
>> SPEAKER: WELL TIM, WELCOME
TO THE LIBRARY OF CONGRESS.
THANK YOU FOR AGREEING TO KICK
OFF OUR WEEK OF BIBLIODISCOTHEQUE.
THIS IS QUITE AN HONOR FOR US.
>> SPEAKER: ROBERT,
I HAVE TO BE HONEST,
WHEN I RECEIVED THE INVITATION.
FIRST OF ALL, LIBRARY OF
CONGRESS, I'M ECSTATIC.
I MEAN THE WHOLE IDEA OF BEING HERE.
AND THEN I THOUGHT DISCO FASHION.
[LAUGHTER].
IT'S -- BUT THEN I FELT THE
LIBRARY OF CONGRESS HAS EVERYTHING.
AND YOU DO.
SO WHY NOT?
>> SPEAKER: IT'S TRUE.
WE DO. WE ARE -- WE ARE
GROUND ZERO FOR INFORMATION
ABOUT THE DISCO ERA, MUSIC, FASHION.
AS YOU CAN SEE, A LITTLE
BIT OF EVERYTHING.
>> SPEAKER: IT TAKES ME BACK.
[LAUGHTER].
>> SPEAKER: IT'S ALSO FUN BECAUSE
YOU'RE A FELLOW WASHINGTONIAN.
>> SPEAKER: I AM, GENERATIONS.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE].
>> SPEAKER: AND A GRADUATE
OF CORCHRAN CULTURE.
>> SPEAKER: YES.
FOR FIVE YEARS.
>> SPEAKER: SO TELL US HOW DID
YOU MORPH FROM CROCHRAN MAJOR.
>> SPEAKER: WELL, HOW
MUCH TIME DO WE HAVE.
EVEN GETTING TO THE CORCHRAN
WAS A SERENDIPITOUS PATH
AND I HAD AN UNDER GRADUATE DEGREE.
I DIDN'T KNOW WHAT I WAS GOING
TO BE DOING IN LITERATURE.
I STUDIED ARCHITECTURE.
AFTER ONE SEMESTER OF IT, I
THOUGHT THIS IS A SURE TRIP
TO AN INSANE ASYLUM.
YOU CAN ONLY IMAGINE PULLING INK
AND A STYLUS ALONG A STRAIGHT AGE
AND 20 HOURS INTO A DRAWING,
THE WHOLE THING BLEEDS.
I GRADUATED FROM CORCHRAN
AND I THOUGHT HOW AM I GOING
TO SUPPORT MYSELF AS
A STARVING SCULPTOR.
AND I WENT BACK IN WASHINGTON, BUT
IN A DIFFERENT FORM OF DEPARTURE.
AND I WAS INVITED TO
TEACH AT THE CORCHRAN.
AND IT WAS ANOTHER
TRIP TO THE ASYLUM.
FOR A WHILE I THREW UP EVERY
MORNING IN THE PARKING LOT.
I HAD A WONDERFUL WOMAN
WHO HIRED ME.
A WONDERFUL WOMAN.
AND DURING THE WEEK I KEPT
REHEARSNG THE TALK I NEEDED TO HAVE
WITH HER FRIDAY AFTERNOON
AFTER CLASS.
I THOUGHT I CAN'T DO THIS.
AND SOMEONE ELSE DECIDED
THEY CANNOT RETURN TO TEACH.
AND I HAD THIS WONDERFUL
IMPASSIONED SPEECH.
I WASN'T EATING.
I WASN'T SLEEPING.
AND LIFE DOESN'T MATTER ANYMORE.
SHE LISTENED TO ME.
SHE SAYS I TRUST THAT THIS WILL
EITHER CHANGE YOU OR KILL YOU.
AND I THOUGHT THE LATER.
OH, NO. I GOT TO GO BACK ON MONDAY.
BUT CURED ME IT DID.
I ENDED UP BEING A CAREER ACADEMIC.
29 YEARS IN THE CLASSROOM.
SO I WAS INVITED TO TEACH AT PARSONS
SCHOOL OF DESIGN IN NEW YORK.
THIS WAS 1982.
AND I SAID NO, NO, NO.
THANK YOU.
I LOVE WASHINGTON.
HAD A GREAT RELATIONSHIP.
AND THERE WERE LOTS OF THINGS
THAT WERE HAPPENING FOR ME.
IT'S VERY INTERESTING
HOW MUCH LIFE CAN CHANGE.
AS QUICKLY AS EIGHT OR NINE MONTHS.
THINGS CHANGE QUITE DRAMATICALLY.
AND I DIDN'T KNOW WHERE I WAS GOING
TO GO OR WHAT I WAS GOING TO DO.
AND THE PHONE RANG IN THE
OLDERN DAYS WITH THE RING RING.
AND IT WAS PARSONS SAYING
WE ARE TRYING AGAIN.
AND I SAID I WILL COME UP
AND INTERVIEW AND WE'LL SEE.
AND TWO WEEKS LATER I
WAS LIVING IN NEW YORK.
AND THAT WAS 34 YEARS AGO.
SO ITS BEEN A LONG RIDE.
NOW, I HAD ANOTHER ROLE AT
PARSONS OR EVENTUALLY DID.
IN 1990 I WAS APPOINTED
ASSOCIATE DEAN.
AND IN THAT CAPACITY I
WORKED WITH DEPARTMENTS
WITH CURRICULUM DEVELOPMENTS
AND FACULTY HIRING
AND FULL-TIME FACULTY
HIRING AND CHAIR HIRINGS.
BUT MOST OF IT WAS CLEAN UP.
PEOPLE CALLED ME MR. FIX-IT.
AND I CALLED MYSELF
A POOPER SCOOPER.
AND I WOULD SAY THIS PLACE
HAS TO STOP POOPING SO MUCH.
AND IT WAS.
AND THAT'S HOW I LANDED
IN THE FASHION DEPARTMENT.
I NEVER -- PEOPLE SAY WHEN DID
YOU FALL IN LOVE WITH FASHION?
WELL, IT WAS WITH A
BAYNETTE IN MY BACK.
I NEVER INTENDED TO BE PART OF THE
FASHION WORLD, IN ANY CAPACITY.
WE HAD A CRISIS OF LEADERSHIP
IN OUR FASHION PROGRAM.
WHICH AT THE TIME, WELL, IT STILL
IS ARGUABLY THE MOST FAMOUS PROGRAM
AT PARSONS.
WE HAVE A CRISIS OF LEADERSHIP.
I WAS SENT IN TO CONDUCT A
SEARCH FOR THE NEW CHAIR.
AND WHEN I STARTED MY EXCAVATION
OF ISSUES, I WENT BACK TO THE DEAN
AND SAID THIS IS NOT A QUICK FIX.
AND IT'S NOT SOMETHING
THAT AN OUTSIDER CAN DO.
AND HE SAID, WELL I WANT
YOU TO GO IN FOR A YEAR.
SO THAT WAS THE DEAL.
I WOULD THERE FOR A YEAR.
AND THE LIMITS TO THE
YEAR WERE THE FOLLOWING.
I WENT IN, IN AUGUST.
THE BUDGET SET JULY 1ST.
FACULTY CONTRACTS WERE SET.
ROOM ASSIGNMENTS, I
MEAN EVERYTHING WAS LAID
OUT FOR YOU FOR THE COMING YEAR.
THERE IS REALLY NOTHING YOU CAN
DO EXCEPT OBSERVE AND PROBE.
I ASKED MILLIONS AND
MILLIONS OF QUESTIONS.
SO AFTER ABOUT THREE MONTHS
THERE, I WROTE A STATE
OF THE UNION OF SORTS TO THE DEAN.
SAYING THIS PLACE IS HEMORRHAGING.
IT'S NOT A QUICK FIX.
IT'S MUCH WORSE THAN I EVER DREAMED.
AND CALLING IT FASHION DESIGN,
IT'S A DRESS MAKING SCHOOL.
IT REALLY WAS.
THERE WAS NO TALK ABOUT
CONCEPTUAL DEVELOPMENT.
THERE WAS NO FASHION HISTORY.
OH, I ASKED, HOW CAN THIS BE?
WE DON'T WANT THE STUDENTS
TO BE INFLUENCED.
CAN YOU IMAGINE?
SO BURY YOURSELF IN A
BASEMENT AND PRETEND
THAT FASHION HASN'T BEEN
AROUND SINCE MILLENIA.
AND NOTHING IS DIGITAL.
IT'S THE YEAR 2000.
SO I WILL FAST FORWARD.
I ENDED UP BEING APPOINTED CHAIR.
NOTHING THAT I INTENDED TO DO.
I HAVE TO TELL YOU A FUNNY STORY.
A DEAR FRIEND OF MINE
FOR MANY YEARS,
IT'S DIANNE VON FOSTENBURG,
SHE IS A DOLL.
SHE WAS MY GO-TO PERSON
FOR ANY KIND OF DILEMMA.
SHE IS A REAL PROBLEM
SOLVER AND KNOWS HOW
TO ASK THE RIGHT QUESTIONS.
AND SHE KNOWS HOW TO
DIAGNOSE AND PRESCRIBE.
SO SHE WAS MEETING WITH ME
IN MY NEW OFFICE AS CHAIR.
AND I WAS VERY AWARE
JUST IN TERMS AURA
THAT SOMETHING WAS VERY DIFFERENT.
AND I LOOKED AT HER.
AND I SAID WHAT'S THE MATTER?
AND SHE LOOKED ME UP AND DOWN.
AND SHE SAID, YOU NEED NEW CLOTHES.
SHE SAID YOU CANNOT BE RUNNING
THIS DEPARTMENT LOOKING LIKE THIS.
AND I SAID IT'S THAT BAD?
SHE SAID IT ALWAYS HAS BEEN.
I JUST NEVER HAD A NEED TO TELL YOU.
[LAUGHTER].
>> SPEAKER: WHAT A
GREAT PIECE OF ADVICE.
I LIKE IT.
>> SPEAKER: BUT I HAVE TO TELL
YOU ANOTHER FUNNY STORY HAVING
TO DO WITH DIANNE.
I'M SORRY I'M STRAYING.
I HAVE THIS WAY OF TALKING.
>> SPEAKER: PLEASE GO ON.
I LOVE IT.
>> SPEAKER: AS A CHAIR, THERE
WERE CERTAIN THINGS I HAD TO DO.
CURRICULUM WAS A HUGE ONE.
FACULTY WAS ANOTHER.
THERE WAS A VERY POWERFUL
FACULTY MEMBER WHO --
AND I SAY POWERFUL BECAUSE HE
ASSERTED HIMSELF INTO EVERYTHING.
AND DID SO VERY INAPPROPRIATELY.
BUT IT HAD BEEN GOING ON FOR YEARS.
AND MANY WAYS, THE
PRECEDENT HAD BEEN SET.
AND WHO IS TO SAY TO HIM YOU
CANNOT DO THE FOLLOWING THINGS?
AND I THOUGHT, WELL I'M THE
ONE WHO IS GOING TO SAY IT.
HIM. I MEAN I COULD HAVE.
I KNEW POLITICALLY IT
WOULD BE VERY DANGEROUS.
I WAS LIKE OKAY, I NEED
TO GET TO GUY TO QUIT.
SO I WROTE HIM A VERY
MATTER-FACT LETTER LAYING OUT,
HERE ARE YOUR RESPONSIBILITIES
AND HERE THE THINGS
THAT YOU HAVE BEEN DOING
AND WILL NO LONGER BE DOING.
AND SENT IT.
WAS WAIT FOR THE REPERCUSSIONS AND
WITHIN ABOUT 10 DAYS THIS ENORMOUS,
I MEAN ENORMOUS ENVELOPE ARRIVED.
AND IT WAS HARD.
I MEAN, YOU COULDN'T REALLY
-- YOU COULDN'T BEND IT.
I THOUGHT, WHAT IS THIS?
WELL, THIS INDIVIDUAL WAS AN
EXTREMELY TALENTED ARTIST.
I PULL OUT THIS DOCUMENT THAT
LOOKS LIKE A MID EVIL MANUSCRIPT.
I MEAN, IT WAS SPECTACULARLY
STUNNING WITH GOLD LEAF AND DRAGONS.
AND I READ IT.
AND IT BEGAN WITH I RECEIVED
YOUR MENACNG MISSION.
AND IT CONCLUDED WITH I QUIT.
I WAS THRILLED.
>> SPEAKER: WOW.
>> SPEAKER: SO A FEW WEEKS
LATER, DIANNE WAS IN THE OFFICE.
AND I WAS VERY LUCKY TO HAVE
MY OWN LITTLE PRIVATE RESTROOM
IN MY OFFICE.
SO I TOOK THIS THING, THIS DOCUMENT,
AND HUNG IT BEHIND THE BATHROOM
DOOR, WHICH FACES THE TOILET.
SO DIANNE GOES TO THE
BATHROOM AND CALLS OUT,
WHAT'S A MENACING MISSIVE.
>> SPEAKER: DO YOU STILL HAVE IT.
>> SPEAKER: YEAH.
>> SPEAKER: YOU'RE BRAVE.
>> SPEAKER: AND PROJECT
RUNWAY CALLED.
AND I MADE -- I WILL SAY THIS
MODESTLY, BUT ALSO RATHER --
WHAT'S THE WORD I AM SEARCHING FOR?
I'LL JUST SAY THIS MODESTLY.
I HAD TO MAKE CHANGES
IN THE DEPARTMENT.
AND THEY WERE VERY
CONTROVERSIAL IN THE CASES.
AND MANY PEOPLE, PARTICULARLY
ALUMNI HATED ME.
I WAS REALLY UNPOPULAR.
I TOOK THIS PRECIOUS THING.
THIS FASHION DESIGN DEPARTMENT
THAT HADN'T CHANGED IN 52 YEARS
AND TURNED IT UPSIDE DOWN.
MY PREDECESSORS WERE
KEEPERS OF THE LINE.
AND MY PRODUCER HEARD
A LOT ABOUT ME.
YOU SHOULD GO TALK TO HIM.
HE MADE A LOT OF CHANGES.
ENDS WERE VERY GOOD.
AND MAYBE HE CAN HELP
YOU WITH THIS PROJECT.
SO THEY CALLED ME.
AND I SAID -- I'LL TELL
YOU EXACTLY WHAT I SAID.
FASHION REALITY?
THIS INDUSTRY HAS ENOUGH
TROUBLE WITHOUT THAT.
SO THEY ASKED IF THEY
CAN COME MEET WITH ME.
AND OF COURSE, I GOOGLED THEM.
AND I FOUND OUT THEY WERE THE
PRODUCERS OF PROJECT GREEN LIGHT
WHICH HAS A LOT OF
INTEGRITY AND PURPOSE.
AND THEY MET WITH ME.
AND I BECAME VERY EXCITED.
THEY WANTED TO WORK WITH
REAL FASHION DESIGNERS
AND IT SOUNDED INTERESTING.
IT SOUNDED INTERESTING AND FUN.
BUT THEY ASKED ME A QUESTION THAT I
KNEW WAS "THE QUESTION" SO TO SPEAK.
AND IT WAS THE FOLLOWING.
HOW WOULD YOU RESPOND IF WE WERE TO
TELL YOU THAT WE WANT THE DESIGNERS
TO CREATE A WEDDING
DRESS IN TWO DAYS?
COMPARED TO PROJECT RUNWAY TODAY,
TWO DAYS SOUNDS LIKE AN ETERNITY.
AND I MEAN, I COME FROM
THE ACADEMIC WORLD.
AND WE HAVE ARCHITECTURE WHERE
YOU GET A PROJECT ON FRIDAY NIGHT
AND CRITIQUING IT ON SUNDAY.
AND IN FACT, WE'LL HAVE TO CREATE
A WEDDING DRESS IN TWO DAYS.
IT CAN BE DONE.
WELL, IT CAN BE DONE.
IT'S NOT GOING TO BE AN OSCAR
LAUREN OR A VERA WANG GOWN,
BUT IT WILL BE A SHIP
WITHOUT SLEEVES.
ACTUALLY A COLUMN WITHOUT SLEEVES.
AND THEN I DIDN'T HEAR
FROM THEM FOR WEEKS.
AND I THOUGHT WELL,
THAT WAS INTERESTING.
AND I WAS THEIR CONSULTANT
UP UNTIL TWO DAYS BEFORE THE
DESIGNERS ARRIVED.
IN A WAY, I'M STILL
THEIR CONSULTANT.
BUT TWO DAYS BEFORE THE DESIGNERS
ARRIVED, THEY ASKED ME IF I WOULD GO
INTO THE WORK ROOM AND PUMBLE
THE DESIGNERS WITH QUESTIONS
ABOUT WHAT THEY ARE DOING.
AND I THOUGHT, THAT'S HOW
I SPENT MOST OF MY LIFE.
SURE. I TOLD YOU BACK
STAGE, I NEVER DREAMED
OF BEING THE CUT OF THE SHOW.
I THOUGHT AS LONG AS THEY HAVE
THE DESIGNERS RESPONDING TO ME,
NO ONE NEEDS TO HEAR MY VOICE.
NO ONE NEEDS TO SEE ME.
AND FOR THAT REASON, I DIDN'T
GO TO THE PREMIERE PARTY.
WELL, IF I'M IN THE SHOW.
WHAT WILL I LOOK LIKE
AND SOUND LIKE?
AND IF I'M NOT IN THE SHOW,
I WILL BE KIND OF HUMILIATED.
SO I WATCHED THE PREMIERE
ON TELEVISION.
I WATCHED IT, THE SAME WAY THAT I
USED TO WATCH "THE WIZARD OF OZ"
WHERE I WAS IN BED PEEKING
OUT FROM BEHIND MY SHEETS.
I HADN'T SEEN ANYTHING IN ADVANCE.
I THOUGHT, I DON'T KNOW
WHAT THEY'RE GOING TO SHOW.
MAYBE IT'S SEXUAL ESCAPADES
IN THE APARTMENT.
I HAVE NO IDEA.
AND THE FIRST FIVE AS SOON AS
OF THE SHOW WE WERE ON BRAVO
AND DURING THE TAPING
OF THE FIRST SEASON,
THERE WAS A WOMAN STANDING NEXT
TO ME IN THE DARKNESS OF THE BACK
OF THE PARSONS AUDITORIUM
WHERE WE FILMED THE RUNWAY SHOW
WITH THE DESIGNERS AND
THE JUDGE'S DELIBERATION.
AND WE WERE WATCHING THE
JUDGE'S DELIBERATION.
AND THIS PERSON, UNKNOWN TO
ME, TURNED TO ME AND ASKED,
WHO IS GOING TO WANT TO WATCH THIS?
AND THE PERSON WAS THE
PRESIDENT OF BRAVO.
[LAUGHTER].
SO WHO KNEW?
I MEAN, AND ALSO AT AGE 50, I HAD AN
ENTIRELY NEW THRESHOLD TO MY LIFE.
I MEAN, IT WAS PHENOMENAL.
AND I HAD A VERY HAPPY, VERY
REWARDING SPIRITUALLY CAREER.
>> SPEAKER: SO OVER THE COURSE OF
PROJECT RUNWAY, HOW HAVE YOU CHANGED
AS ONE WHO CRITIQUES DESIGN
AS A TEACHER, AS A MENTOR?
>> SPEAKER: THAT'S AN
INTERESTING QUESTION.
WELL, ACTUALLY, BECOMING A
MENTOR WAS VERY CHALLENGING.
IN WAYS THAT I DIDN'T
THINK THAT IT WOULD.
BECAUSE I BECAME AWARE
VERY QUICKLY THAT I HAD
TO TAKE OFF MY TEACHER'S HAT AND
ACTUALLY IT HAPPENED, EPISODE 1.
SEASON 1 EPISODE 1.
I WAS IN THE SEWING
ROOM THREADING A BOBBIN.
BECAUSE ONE OF THE DESIGNERS
WAS HAVING DIFFICULTY DOING IT.
JANE LIPSIT ONE OF THE
EXECUTIVE PRODUCERS IS KNOCKING
BECAUSE SHE HAS A FEED, THERE
IS A FEED IN EVERY ROOM.
KNOCKING ON THE SEWING ROOM DOOR.
SAYING TIM, CAN I SPEAK
TO YOU IN THE HALLWAY?
WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
I'M THREADING A BOBBIN.
SHE SAID YOU CAN'T DO THAT.
WHY NOT? BECAUSE IT'S
A FAIRNESS ISSUE.
IF YOU THREAD THE BOBBIN
FOR THAT DESIGNER,
YOU HAVE TO THREAD THE BOBBIN
FOR ALL OF THE DESIGNERS.
AND I SAID I'M OUT OF THE
SEWING ROOM AND I'M NOT GOING
TO BECOME THE BOBBING
THREADING HAND MAIDEN.
AND I ALSO LEARNED
DURING THE CRITIQUES --
AND I HAVE BEEN LIKE THIS.
THE MENTOR YOU SEE IN THE
WORK ROOM IS VERY MUCH THE WAY
THAT I EVOLVED AS A TEACHER.
BECAUSE IN THE EARLY
DAYS OF TEACHING,
I THINK IT'S SOMEWHAT NATURAL
FOR AT LEAST NOVICES TO WANT
TO MAKE SURE STUDENTS
INTO LITTLE MINI ME'S.
I WANT YOU TO HAVE THE SAME -- WORK
HABITS AND ALL OF THE MYRIAD THINGS
THAT GO WITH THAT, PUCTUALITY
AND BREAK TIME AND THE THING
THAT I EVOLVED TO WAS,
WHAT ARE YOU TRYING TO DO?
AND HOW WELL ARE YOU
SUCCEEDING AT THIS?
WHAT ISSUES ARE YOU HAVING?
I DEVELOPED A VERY SOCRATIC
APPROACH TO TEACHING.
HUMBLING PEOPLE WITH QUESTIONS.
AND I WILL SAY THIS FOR ANY TEACHERS
OR WOULD-BE TEACHERS IN THIS ROOM.
AND ANOTHER THING THAT
I RID MYSELF UP.
THE DEBILITATING THROWING UP PART OF
IT, FEELING THAT I WAS RESPONSIBLE
FOR EVERY KERNEL OF INFORMATION.
THAT I HAD TO BE THIS
VUNDER KENT ANSWER MAN.
AND IT WAS JUST DEBILITATING.
SO WHAT I EVOLVED TO, IF
SOMEONE WERE TO ASK A QUESTION,
IF A STUDENT WERE TO ASK A QUESTION.
I WOULD SAY, INTERESTING QUESTION.
FOR THE NEXT CLASS, I WANT ALL
OF YOU TO RESEARCH THIS QUESTION.
AND COME IN WITH AN ANSWER THAT
YOU DON'T THINK ANYONE ELSE WOULD
HAVE FOUND.
SO THEY HAD TO DIG DEEP.
AND THEN WE WOULD SHARE IT ALL.
AND IT WAS FANTASTIC.
BECAUSE THE CONVERSATION
THAT WOULD EVOLVE
FROM THAT ONE QUESTION WOULD BE A
CATALYST FOR A MILLION OTHER THINGS
AND WOULD TAKE US INTO A DIRECTION
OF A MILLION OTHER THINGS,
AND WAS A HUGE ENHANCEMENT FOR THE
COURSE SYLLABUS AND FOR ME TO MOVE
INTO THE MENTOR POSITION ON RUNWAY.
I WON'T SAY IT WAS EASY.
I WAS A NERVOUS WRECK.
I WAS ESPECIALLY A NERVOUS
WRECK IF HEIDI WAS EVER AROUND.
MY PALMS WOULD SWEAT.
SHE IS VERY -- I MEAN SHE
IS A LOVELY FANTASTIC PERSON
WHO I LOVE DEARLY.
BUT SHE IS HEIDI KLUM.
>> SPEAKER: YEAH.
THAT CAN BE VERY INTIMIDATNG
I'M SURE.
>> SPEAKER: BUT IT WAS A JOURNEY.
>> SPEAKER: RIGHT.
>> SPEAKER: AND ONE
THAT I REALLY LOVED.
>> SPEAKER: SO WHAT IS IT LIKE
ACTUALLY DOING PROJECT RUNWAY?
HOW LONG DOES IT TAKE YOU TO DO IT?
>> SPEAKER: WELL WE DO THE
BULK OF IT WHICH CONSISTS
OF 12 CHALLENGES IN 31 DAYS.
WE HAVE NO BREAKS.
SOMETIMES 18 HOUR,
SOMETIMES 20 HOUR DAYS.
I LOVE PROJECT RUNWAY JUNIOR.
WE HAVE TO ABIDE BY
THE CHILD LABOR LAWS.
IT'S LIKE A VACATION.
IT'S SO WONDERFUL.
THE DAY ENDS AND EVERYONE
IS OFF THE CLOCK.
FOR RUNWAY, IF IT'S DECIDED THAT THE
WORK ROOM IS GOING TO NOT CLOSE AT
AND WE STAY OPEN UNTIL , WE
SHARE IT WITH THE AUDIENCE.
WE NEVER MISREPRESENT THINGS.
AND THEN I'M THERE UNTIL .
IT'S FINE.
IT'S A HIGH CLASS PROBLEM.
THE LONG DAYS.
AND I WILL SAY, IT
GETS TO ALL OF US.
I MEAN, IT'S A CUMULATIVE
EXHAUSTION.
MENTALLY, PHYSICALLY, CREATIVELY.
IT GETS TO US.
BUT I WOULDN'T NOT DO IT.
AND IT'S FOR BUDGET
REASONS THAT WE DO IT
IN SUCH A SHORT PERIOD OF TIME.
AND THERE IS A HIATUS.
AND I DO THE HOME VISIT WHICH
IS 10 DAYS INCLUDING TRAVEL.
AND THEN THERE IS ANOTHER
VERY SMALL HIATUS
AND THEN WE HAVE FASHION WEEK.
WHICH TAKES US FIVE
DAYS BEGINNING TO END.
>> SPEAKER: WONDERFUL.
WELL, ONE OF THE REASONS THAT
WE'RE HERE IS TO CELEBRATE DISCO.
THE WHOLE DISCO ERA AND WE'RE
BOTH PRODUCTS OF THAT ERA.
>> SPEAKER: REGRETTABLY.
>> SPEAKER: WHAT DO YOU THINK
DEFINES DISCO IN TERMS OF FASHION?
>> SPEAKER: WELL, I WANT TO
GIVE IT A BIT OF A CONTEXT.
WE'RE COMING OUT OF THE
1960S, WHICH WAS IN MY VIEW,
THE MOST REVOLUTIONARY
DECADE IN FASHION EVER.
I MEAN, WE USHERED IN WITH MAD MEN
PRIMNUS AND BUTTONED UPNESS FOR MEN.
AND WE USHER IT OUT WITH HIPPIES.
AND WE HAVE THE CLEAR VINYL
DRESS COURTESY OF YSL.
WE HAVE THE PAPER DRESS.
THAT'S WHY TODAY, ESPECIALLY
THOSE, OH,
GOD THOSE HORRIBLE
KARDASHIANS RUNNING AROUND.
[LAUGHTER].
I'LL BE HONEST WITH YOU.
THE ONLY THING THAT MAKES
ME RISE MORE IS WHAT'S GOING
ON IN THE WHITE HOUSE.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE].
BUT TRULY, AFTER THE '60S, FASHION
WISE, I'M PRETTY UNSHOCKABLE.
SO WE HAVE THIS TERM OIL.
WE ENTER INTO THE '70S AND THERE
ARE CERTAIN ASPECTS OF IT BROAD MEN.
WE HAD A PEACOCK MOMENT OF MEN IN
THE '60S WITH EXTRAVAGANT DRESS
AND MELTED BEAUTIFULLY INTO
THE WHOLE DISCO MOVEMENT.
WE HAD A KIND OF BODY
AWARENESS WITH WOMEN.
WHERE VERY LITTLE WAS
LEFT TO THE IMAGINATION.
AND THAT CERTAINLY SEGUED
VERY BEAUTIFULLY INTO DISCO.
IT WAS A TIME OF FLAMBOYANCE.
IT WAS A TIME OF DIFFERENTIATION
AND EVERYONE WANTED TO STAND OUT.
I AM ALWAYS TALKING
ABOUT THE CLOTHES,
THE CLOTHES WE WEAR SEND A MESSAGE
ABOUT HOW THE WORLD PERCEIVES US.
YOU WANTED TO BE DISTINCTIVE AND
DIFFERENT ON THAT DISCO DANCE FLOOR.
IT WAS REALLY A GIANT
RUNWAY OF SORTS.
AND IT WAS SEXUALLY CHARGED.
SOCIOLOGICALLY CHARGED.
IDENTITY CHARGED.
THERE WERE GENDER-BENDING
ASPECTS TO DISCO CULTURE.
AND WE SEE THE RISE OF CERTAIN
DESIGNERS IN THAT PERIOD
WHO ALSO WERE INEXTRICABLE
FROM THE MOVEMENT.
HOLTSTON BEING THE MOST PROMINENT,
WORKING WITH JERSEY
WHO HAD STRETCHED.
HOW CRAZY WOULD IT BE WEARING
HOLTSTON ON THE DANCE FLOOR.
DIANNE VON FURSTENBURG ANOTHER,
NORMA CANOLLI, ICONIC IN THE '70S
AND ENTRENCHED IN DISCO CULTURE.
IT WAS A PHENOMENAL TIME.
AND IT'S DEBATABLE, AND ARGUABLE.
BUT MANY PEOPLE SAY
THAT DISCO CULTURE CAME
OUT OF A GAY SUBCULTURE.
AND I BELIEVE THAT.
IN MANY WAYS IT DID.
AND COINCIDENTALLY, I AM SURE
MANY OF YOU ARE ENTIRELY TOO YOUNG
TO HAVE ANY AWARENESS OF THIS.
IN SOME WAYS I THINK YOU SHOULD.
IN 1973 HOMO SEXUALITY
WAS REMOVED FROM THE LIST
OF PSYCHIATRIC DISORDERS BY THE
AMERICAN MEDICAL ASSOCIATION.
SO SUDDENLY YOU DIDN'T HAVE
TO WORRY ABOUT BEING OUT.
BECAUSE PRIOR TO THAT,
TO YOU CAN BE LOCKED UP.
I MEAN, LEGALLY.
SO THIS SUBCULTURE COULD
EMERGE AND BECOME --
I DON'T WANT TO SAY MAIN STREAM.
BUT ACTUALLY EMBRACED
BY THE MAIN STREAM.
I MEAN, THE WONDERFUL THING ABOUT
DISCO CULTURE, IT WAS ALL INCLUSIVE.
IT DIDN'T CARE WHERE YOU
CAME FROM, WHO YOU WERE,
WHAT YOUR IDENTITY WAS,
WHAT RACE YOU WERE.
IT EMBRACED EVERYBODY.
AND IT WAS -- ACTUALLY I
DID A LITTLE BIT OF RESEARCH
IN IF ANTICIPATION OF OUR INTERVIEW.
I THOUGHT, WHAT DO I
REALLY KNOW ABOUT THIS?
I DIDN'T REALIZE THAT BY
1978 IN THIS COUNTRY ALONE,
THERE WERE ,000 DISCO TECHS.
>> SPEAKER: OH, I HAD NO IDEA.
>> SPEAKER: THAT'S
A STAGGERING NUMBER.
>> SPEAKER: IT IS.
>> SPEAKER: AND OF COURSE THE GRAND
PUBA OF THEM ALL WAS STUDIO 54.
>> SPEAKER: YEAH.
AMAZING. SO FROM THIS
PERIOD, DO YOU HAVE ANY KIND
OF YOUR OWN FASHION RECOLLECTION?
THINGS THAT YOU WERE WEARING?
IS THERE ANYTHING IN YOUR CLOSET
THAT YOU WANT TO TELL US ABOUT?
[LAUGHTER].
>> SPEAKER: YOU KNOW, I HAVE THIS
THEORY CALLED THE MONKEY HOUSE
AT THE ZOO.
AND IT IS THE FOLLOWING.
WHEN YOU FIRST WALK INTO THE MONKEY
HOUSE, YOU SHRIEK THIS PLACE STINKS.
AND AFTER 20 MINUTES YOU SAY,
THIS DOESN'T SMELL SO BAD.
AND AFTER 30 MINUTES,
YOU THINK, WHAT SMELL?
BUT ANYONE NEW WALKING IN
SAYS THIS PLACE STINKS.
THAT WAS MY '70S FASHION.
I PUT ON THE POLYESTER
PANTS AND THE FLORAL SHIRT
AND I THOUGHT THIS IS
UNACCEPTABLE AND ATROCIOUS.
AND AFTER 20 MINUTES, I THOUGHT
YOU KNOW, I LOOK KIND OF HIP.
AND AFTER 30 MINUTES, I THOUGHT,
OKAY, I CAN LEAVE MY APARTMENT NOW.
BUT LOOKING BACK AT IT,
WHAT WERE WE THINKING?
>> SPEAKER: RIGHT.
WELL, TIM, I WENT INTO MY CLOSET.
>> SPEAKER: WHAT DID YOU FIND?
>> SPEAKER: [LAUGHTER].
>> SPEAKER: ROBERT
YOU STILL HAVE THEM?
ARE YOU WAITING FOR THE RETURN?
>> SPEAKER: I WISH I
CAN GET MY FOOT IN THEM.
1977, I BOUGHT THESE IN PARIS.
I WAS STUDYING IN FRANCE.
YES, I THOUGHT I WAS THE COOLEST
THING THAT EVER HIT THE EARTH.
>> SPEAKER: WELL, YOU WERE.
>> SPEAKER: SO WHY DO
I STILL HAVE THESE?
>> SPEAKER: WHY DO YOU?
>> SPEAKER: I HAVE NO IDEA.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE].
>> SPEAKER: THAT IS HILARIOUS.
ALL I CAN SAY IS THANK GOD
FOR TINY NEW YORK APARTMENTS.
BECAUSE UNLESS I RESIGN MYSELF
TO BEING A HOARDER,
I GET RID OF THINGS.
THAT'S EXTRAORDINARY.
>> SPEAKER: ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
YOU WERE TELLING ME BACK STAGE,
BACK IN YOUR CAREER THAT
SURPRISED ME WAS THAT YOU HAVE
TO HAVE YOUR OWN WARDROBE.
>> SPEAKER: OH, I DO.
I SUPPLY EVERYTHING.
>> SPEAKER: I THOUGHT YOU
WERE JUST SITTING BACK,
AND PEOPLE WERE HOLDING UP OUTFITS.
>> SPEAKER: NO.
BUT YOU JUST TRIGGERED A STORY
THOUGH THAT HAS LEFT MY MIND.
YEAR ONE OF PROJECT RUNWAY, IT'S
2004, BANANA REPUBLIC WAS ONE
OF THE SPONSORS OF THE SHOW.
IN FACT, WE HAD THE BANANA
REPUBLIC CHALLENGE FIRST TWO YEARS.
AND THEY WERE GOING TO WARDROBE ME.
OUTFIT ME.
AND COINCIDENTALLY, I WAS
A BIG BANANA REPUBLIC FAN.
AND DIANNE VON FURSTENBURG
SAID ARE YOU GOING
TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT THIS.
I WENT TO SAKS AND FOUND A
BLAZER THAT I TRULY LOVED.
IT WAS EXPENSIVE.
AND THEN I WALKED ACROSS THE STREET
TO THE BANANA REPUBLIC OF FLAGSHIP
ACROSS THE STREET BY
ROCKEFELLER CENTER.
I REMEMBER BANANA REPUBLIC BEING
KHAKIS, AND GOING INTO THE AMAZON.
AND I FOUND THE IDENTICAL
JACKET MORE OR LESS
FOR 25 -- FOR 75 PERCENT LESS.
IT WAS A MERE 25 PERCENT
OF THE PRICE.
I BOUGHT IT.
AND TOOK THE JACKET BACK TO SAKS.
AND I DISCOVERED THE
WORLD OF BANANA REPUBLIC.
AND I HAD A LOT OF THE CLOTHES.
AND I WAS THRILLED.
I WAS GOING TO GET NEW STUFF
AND THEY WERE ANTICIPATING
WHEN THE STUFF WOULD BE AIRED,
IT WOULD BE NEW FALL CLOTHES.
AT ANY RATE, NOTHING CAME.
NOTHING CAME.
SO THEN, SOME CALLS WERE MADE,
AND CLOTHES DID ARRIVE TAPED
TO A BICYCLE MESSENGER'S BIKE, A
BAG OF BANANA REPUBLIC CLOTHES.
I WAS WEARING BANANA
REPUBLIC CLOTHES EVERY DAY.
BUT IT WAS MY BANANA
REPUBLIC CLOTHES.
NOT THEIRS.
SO I GOT A STEAMER.
AND WORKED ITSELF OUT.
AND AT THE END OF THE SEASON,
THEY WANTED EVERYTHING
BACK INCLUDING THE SOCKS.
SO I DRY CLEANED EVERYTHING.
AND I HAD MADE CERTAIN ALL
OF THE SOCKS WERE LAUNDERED
AND I WAS THEN LATER ASKED,
THIS IS GETTING REALLY
TEDIOUS, I'M SORRY EVERYONE.
I WAS ASKED, LAUREN DAVID
PENEN WROTE FOR WOMEN'S DAILY
AND HAD A REGULAR FEATURE OF
GIVING SOMEONE 100 DOLLARS
AND WHAT WOULD YOU BUY?
OH, THERE IS A RAIN COAT
ON SALE AT BANANA REPUBLIC
AND IT'S 100 DOLLARS
AND I WILL PAY THE TAX.
AND TALKING ABOUT TAKING
THE CLOTHES BACK.
ALL HELL BROKE LOOSE.
DON'T TAKE THEM BACK
IF YOU DON'T WANT
TO TAKE RESPONSIBILITY FOR THEM.
I WAS FLABBERGASTED.
SEASON TWO, BANANA REPUBLIC IS BACK.
AND I AM STILL WEARING
BANANA REPUBLIC.
I'M WEARING THEIR CLOTHES BUT I'M
TURNED OFF BY THE PUBLIC RELATIONS.
AND THE PEOPLE WITH THE SPONSORS
SAY TO ME, WE NEED AN INVENTORY
OF EVERYTHING YOU WORE THIS SEASON.
WHY? WE NEED TO CREDIT
BANANA REPUBLIC WITH IT.
I SAID, WELL I'M WEARING BANANA
REPUBLIC BUT IT'S ALL MINE.
THE CLOTHES NEVER CAME.
AND THEY DIDN'T.
ONCE AGAIN, ALL HELL BROKE LOOSE.
I MEAN, I LOVE BEING
I A TRUTH TELLER.
BUT IT DOES CAUSE SOME PROBLEMS.
I AM RESPONSIBLE FOR MY WARDROBE.
AND I TAKE THAT ROLE VERY SERIOUSLY.
AND IT MEANS THAT I NEED TO
GET NEW THINGS EVERY YEAR.
AND I TAKE A LOT OF THINGS TO
GOOD WILL AND HOUSING WORKS
BECAUSE I HAVE SMALL NEW YORK
CLOSETS AND IF ANYONE IS WONDERING,
NO, YOU CAN'T WRITE
THEM OFF IN YOUR TAXES.
ONCE ANYTHING LEAVES THE STUDIO,
OF COURSE I'M ON THE SUBWAY EVERY
DAY, SO IT LEAVES THE STUDIO.
I DON'T HAVE A DRESSING ROOM.
I DON'T HAVE A PLACE TO CHANGE.
SO IT'S MINE.
BUT THAT ALSO MEANS I CAN
DO WHAT I WANT WITH IT.
>> SPEAKER: THAT'S GREAT.
WELL, TIM WE'RE GOING
TO TURN IN A MOMENT JUST
TO SOME QUESTIONS FROM THE AUDIENCE.
>> SPEAKER: OH, THRILLING.
>> SPEAKER: IT WILL BE FUN.
BUT I HAVE TWO MORE QUESTIONS THAT
EVERYBODY REALLY WANTS TO KNOW.
AND I MUST GIVE THEM TO YOU NOW.
>> SPEAKER: UH-OH.
>> SPEAKER: THE FIRST
IS, DO YOU HAVE A TATTOO?
>> SPEAKER: YOU KNOW, IT'S
SOMETHING I FANTASIZE ABOUT.
AND AT THE MOMENT, NO.
BECAUSE I HAVE A SERIOUS
ADVERSION TO PAIN.
BUT IF I WAS TO EVER GET A
TATTOO, AND HONEST TRUTH,
I HAVE SAID THIS MANY TIMES,
IT WOULD BE MY LIBRARY
OF CONGRESS CATALOG NUMBER.
ONE OF THEM.
>> SPEAKER: BRAVO.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE].
ALSO, IN A WAY, WHEN YOU THINK
ABOUT TATTOOS, AND I MEAN THIS
WITH ALL RESPECT, DON'T
YOU THINK IT'S AN ANTEDOTE.
THIS IS GREAT.
>> SPEAKER: IT'S WONDERFUL.
WE'RE GOING TO GO PLACES WITH THAT.
I'M NOT SURE HOW YET.
BUT WE'RE GOING TO GO THERE.
ACTUALLY JUST TWO MORE THINGS.
COULD YOU GIVE US ANY
DISH ON YOUR CO-STARS?
>> SPEAKER: COULD I?
LET ME PUT IT THIS WAY.
HEIDI IS A DOLL.
THERE ISN'T A DEVIOUS
BONE IN HER BODY.
AND ALL YOU NEED TO KNOW IS
THAT CREW MEMBERS ADORE HER.
THEY DO NOT SEPARATE.
AND THEN THERE ARE THE OTHER TWO.
I HAVE TO INTERACT WITH
THEM SINCE SEASON 12.
I HAVE HAD TO SIT WITH
THEM FOR THE RUNWAY SHOW.
I'M TELLING YOU, COMING
DOWN THE RUNWAY.
WE'RE SUPPOSED TO BE LOOKING AT IT.
AND FOR ME, YOU CAN SAY, YOU
ALREADY KNOW WHAT THE WORK IS.
NO, I HAVEN'T SEEN IT WALK.
I HAVEN'T SEEN IT ON MODELS.
I HAVEN'T SEEN HOW
THE PROPORTIONS WORK
WITH THE PROPORTIONS OF THE BODY.
I HAVEN'T SEEN IT WALK.
AND THE JUDGES HAVEN'T
SEEN IT AT ALL.
AT LEAST I SAW IT IN THE WORK ROOM.
I WILL BE SITTING THERE STUDYING
THE SHOW AND NINA WILL LEAN OVER
AND ASK, SO HOW IS YOUR SUMMER?
LOOK AT THE SHOW.
I USED TO SAY, BEFORE I INTERACTED
WITH THEM, THAT I WOULD SAY HELLO
TO THE JUDGES WHEN THEY ARRIVED.
BUT I FREQUENTLY DIDN'T SAY
GOOD BYE BECAUSE I WAS MAD.
SO I STILL DON'T SAY GOOD BYE.
BUT I DO SAY HELLO.
>> SPEAKER: THAT'S GOOD.
WELL MY LAST QUESTION IS
REALLY ON THE SERIOUS SIDE.
MANY OF US ARE FAMILIAR
WITH YOUR VERY MOVING VIDEO
ON THE IT GETS BETTER PROJECT.
>> SPEAKER: THANK YOU.
>> SPEAKER: BEAUTIFUL.
[APPLAUSE].
AND YOU HAVE DONE SO MUCH WORK
CHANTING PREVENTION OF TEEN SUICIDE.
AND HOW DO YOU MANAGE ALL OF THE
CHARITABLE WORK THAT YOU'RE DOING
WITH THIS VERY DEMANDING PROFESSION?
>> SPEAKER: WELL, I
CONSIDER IT A RESPONSIBILITY.
YOU JUST HAVE TO MAKE TIME FOR IT.
IT'S VERY, VERY IMPORTANT
TO GIVE BACK.
AND HAVING SPENT MOST OF MY
LIFE, WELL ALL OF MY LIFE REALLY
WITH YOUNG PEOPLE, WITH
ESPECIALLY STUDENTS
AND KNOWING HOW PAINFUL
NAVIGATING THE WORLD CAN BE.
AND GROWING UP CAN BE.
I'M A SQUISH.
I MEAN, I HAVE A SOFT SPOT FOR
THAT KIND OF PAIN AND ANGUISH.
I THOUGHT I WOULD NEVER
BE DELIVERED FROM IT.
AND TO BE ABLE TO SAY
TO PEOPLE, INDIVIDUALS,
IT REALLY DOES GET BETTER.
BUT I HAVE TO SAY THIS
TOO TO EVERYONE.
LIFE IS A COLLABORATION.
WE DO NOT DO THINGS ALONE.
AND WE CERTAINLY DON'T
GET BETTER ALONE.
AND I HAD -- I WAS LUCKY TO HAVE --
I DIDN'T THINK I WAS
LUCKY AT THE TIME.
I THOUGHT IT WAS ABSOLUTELY
HORRIBLE.
I WAS LUCKY TO HAVE AN
INTERVENTION BY AN INCREDIBLE DOCTOR
WHO WOULDN'T PUT UP
WITH MY NONSENSE.
HE SAVED ME.
AND STOOD BY ME.
I'M FOREVER GRATEFUL.
>> SPEAKER: THANK GOD.
SO THANK YOU.
I THINK WE WOULD LIKE TO TURN TO
SOME QUESTIONS FROM THE AUDIENCE.
>> SPEAKER: I LOVE IT.
>> SPEAKER: OUR STAFF
HAS MICROPHONES
AND IT'S KIND OF BRIGHT UP HERE.
ANY QUESTIONS, COME UP.
HERE WE GO.
READY FOR OUR CLOSE UPS.
WE HAVE A QUESTION.
>> SPEAKER: I JUST WANT TO SAY,
YOU'RE A FABULOUS LOOKING AUDIENCE.
[APPLAUSE].
I AM SO GLAD THE LIGHTS WENT UP.
WHERE IS OUR QUESTION?
AUDIENCE MEMBER: HI.
YOU HAVE I THINK THE
BEST WASHINGTON,
D.C. STORY I HAVE EVER HEARD.
I WAS WONDERING IF YOU CAN TELL
US AGAIN ABOUT VIVIAN VINCE.
>> SPEAKER: YES, MY FATHER
WAS AN FBI AGENT FOR 26 YEARS.
AND HE WAS IN A FIELD OFFICE IN
NEWARK, NEW JERSEY OF ALL PLACES
FOR THREE OF THOSE YEARS AND
THEN WAS MOVED TO HEADQUARTERS.
AND MY FATHER WAS A VERY
TALENTED WRITER AND ENDED
UP BEING HOOVER'S GHOST WRITER AND
SPEECH WRITER AND TOOK CARE OF ALL
OF THE CORRESPONDENTS AND MY SISTER
AND I WOULD FIST THE FBI
HEADQUARTERS ONCE A YEAR
AND TAKE THE FBI TOUR.
IT'S A REAL THRILL.
AND IT PROBABLY STILL IS.
AND REMEMBER, THIS IS THE
OLD ER DAYS OF HUBERT.
IT WAS NOT A PRESIDENTIAL
APPOINTMENT.
IN FACT, I HAVE A WHOLE
CONSPIRACY THEORY ABOUT HIS DEATH.
SO THIS ONE PARTICULAR DAY MY
FATHER SAID TO MY SISTER AND ME,
VIVIAN VANCE IS VISITING MR. HOOVER.
AND I WAS A HUGE "I LOVE LUCY" FAN
AND I AM A HUGE "I LOVE LUCY" FAN
AND WAS LIKE, WOULD
YOU LIKE TO MEET HER?
OF COURSE.
WHO WOULDN'T.
IT WAS THRILLING.
IT WAS BEFORE SELFIES AND
LITTLE PORTABLE PHONES
AND THINGS OF THAT SORT.
SO THERE WAS NO DOCUMENTATION.
WE MET VIVIAN VANCE.
IT WAS GREAT.
YEARS LATER, MY FATHER HAS PASSED.
ALL OF THE STUFF COMES OUT ABOUT
HOOVER BEING A CROSS DRESSER.
AND IT WAS THANKSGIVING DINNER
AND I TURN TO MY SISTER.
AND I SAID REMEMBER THE VISIT
TO MR. MR. HOOVER'S OFFICE
WHERE WE MET VIVIAN VANCE.
AND I SAID, DO YOU THINK IT WAS ODD
THAT MR. HOOVER WASN'T
IN THE OFFICE?
PUT A CURLY FRIGHT WIG ON
MR. HOOVER, IT'S MR. MERTZ.
WOW. SO I WROTE ABOUT THIS.
I THINK IT WAS IN RULES.
AND THE CHECKER HAD TO
GO THROUGH EVERYTHING.
AND WHEN I GOT TO THE STORY.
THEY CONTACTED VIVIAN VANCE'S TWO
BIOGRAPHERS AND THEY KNEW NOTHING
ABOUT A VISIT TO THE FBI.
AND THEN THEY CHECKED THE
VISITOR LOGS OF THE FBI.
>> SPEAKER: OH, MY GOSH.
THAT IS SOME WASHINGTON FOOTNOTE.
WOW.
>> SPEAKER: BUT IF VIVIAN
VANCE WERE STILL ALIVE AND WERE
TO VISIT THE WHITE HOUSE,
THERE WOULD STILL BE NO RECORD.
[APPLAUSE].
>> SPEAKER: OH, WE HAVE
A QUESTION RIGHT HERE.
>> SPEAKER: HI.
AUDIENCE MEMBER: HI.
I'M JENNIFER.
OF ALL THE THINGS THAT
YOU SEE CELEBRITIES
THAT ARE JUST PEOPLE
TODAY, THAT WE WEAR,
THAT IS YOUR LEAST FAVORITE TREND?
>> SPEAKER: WHAT IS
MY LEAST FAVORITE?
AUDIENCE MEMBER: TREND.
TREND TODAY.
>> SPEAKER: OH, MY GOD.
I'M GOING TO OFFEND SOME PEOPLE.
CAN I ASK THIS QUESTION?
WHEN DID THE LEGGING BECOME A PANT?
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE].
WHEN DID IT HAPPEN?
YOU KNOW IT'S A CLASSIC
MONKEY HOUSE ITEM.
YOU KNOW IT IS.
I CAN'T GO OUT WEARING THESE.
AND 30 MINUTES LATER, I LOOK HOT.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND IT.
IT'S A FORM OF UNDER GARMENT.
WEAR IT UNDER A TUNIC OR A
PAIR OF SHORTS OR A DRESS.
IT'S NOT A PANT.
>> SPEAKER: YOU HEARD IT
HERE FIRST WASHINGTON, D.C.
>> SPEAKER: REALLY.
>> SPEAKER: OKAY WE
HAVE ONE RIGHT UP HERE.
AUDIENCE MEMBER: HI.
SO MANY OF THE CHALLENGES
ON PROJECT RUNWAY SEEM
TO BE RUN BY THE SPONSORS.
>> SPEAKER: OH, THEY ARE.
AUDIENCE MEMBER: HAVE
YOU EVER GOTTEN ONE
THAT YOU WERE JUST DISGUSTED BY?
>> SPEAKER: YES, BUT FORTUNATELY
WE -- THE SPONSOR GOES AWAY.
BECAUSE HEIDI AND I
SAY WE WON'T DO IT.
WE WON'T DO IT.
IF YOU CAN BELIEVE IT, THE ONES
THAT YOU DO SEE ARE MODIFIED
AND MITIGATED IN SUCH A WAY
THAT THEY ACTUALLY AT LEAST,
FROM MY POINT OF VIEW, WORK.
ALTHOUGH THERE IS SOME EXCEPTIONS.
YEAH. I MEAN THERE ARE TIMES WHEN
HEIDI AND I WERE SUPPOSED TO DRESS
UP AS DETERGENT BOTTLES
AND PRESENT A CHALLENGE.
IF WE DO IT, DO IT
IN LA AND WE'LL GO
ON "LET'S MAKE A DEAL"
OR DO IT ON HALLOWEEN.
WE COULDN'T DO THE SHOWS
WITHOUT THE SPONSORS.
WE HAVE SUCH A SLIM BUDGET.
THERE WOULD BE NO SHOW.
WE DO THE BEST WE CAN WITH IT.
>> SPEAKER: GREAT.
A QUESTION RIGHT HERE.
AUDIENCE MEMBER: HI, TIM GUNN.
I HAVE TWO QUESTIONS.
I'M SORRY.
I WANT TO KNOW WHO YOUR FAVORITE
LOOK WAS AT THE MET GALA LAST NIGHT.
AND WHAT YOUR FAVORITE
BAR IN D.C. IS?
>> SPEAKER: LAST NIGHT.
WELL, I MEAN, HONORING IT'S REALLY A
LICENSE TO WEAR HALLOWEEN COSTUMES.
AND A LOT OF PEOPLE DID.
I TENDED -- I MEAN, PERSONALLY.
I'M AN OLD DUDDY.
I LIKE THE LOOKS.
I THOUGHT JENNIFER
LOPEZ LOOKED FANTASTIC.
BUT WAS SHE OUT OF STEP WITH
THE THEME OF WHAT THE SHOW WAS?
YOU KNOW, I'M NOT PERMITTED
TO ATTEND THE GALA.
I'M VERY PROUD OF THAT.
BECAUSE THE HOSTESS
AND I ARE ARCH ENEMIES.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE].
OH, MY GOODNESS.
DO YOU NOT KNOW THIS STORY?
IT WAS AN OUTCOME OF TRUTH TELLING.
>> SPEAKER: OH, MY GOSH.
>> SPEAKER: DO YOU WANT TO HEAR IT?
>> SPEAKER: IT'S JUST
YOU AND ME, DEAR.
YES.
>> SPEAKER: I WAS BEING INTERVIEWED
BY ROBERT YORK AT THE NEW YORK POST
FOR A COVER STORY THEY WERE
DOING CORRESPONDING TO A PREMIERE
OF PROJECT RUNWAY, A NEW
SEASON OF PROJECT RUNWAY.
AND HE ASKED ME, WHAT IS
THE MOST UNFORGETTABLE THING
THAT YOU HAVE EVER SEEN IN FASHION.
AND HE SAID, I DON'T MEAN
AN ARTICLE OF CLOTHING.
BUT SOMETHING THAT HAS HAPPENED.
AND I SAID OH, THAT'S EASY.
I SAID I WAS WATCHING ANNA WINTOR
BEING CARRIED DOWN FIVE FLIGHTS
OF STAIRS FROM HER FASHION SHOW.
JUST THE FACTS.
NO EDITORIALIZING.
CAME OUT ON SUNDAY OF COURSE.
AND IT WAS A LITTLE BOX.
AND I WAS TEACHING THE
FOLLOWING MONDAY MORNING.
I GET BACK TO MY OFFICE.
SO THIS IS PARSON'S OF COURSE.
AND I WISH I CAN RECREATE
MY EXPRESSION AND MOVEMENTS.
THERE WAS A WHILE YOU WERE
OUT LITTLE POST-IT THING
THAT WAS ALSO LIKE OLD DINOSAURS.
ANNA WINTOR'S OFFICE CALLED.
PLEASE RETURN.
WELL, I WAS -- I THINK
EVERYTHING OPENED.
SO I CALLED.
ACTUALLY I DIDN'T CALL RIGHT AWAY.
I THOUGHT, WHEN WILL SHE
PROBABLY BE AT LUNCH?
YEAH, SO INTUITIVELY, I THOUGHT .
SO I CALLED.
AND SHE WAS AT LUNCH.
SO I THOUGHT OKAY.
DEED DONE.
HOWEVER, SOMEONE ELSE PICKED
UP THE PHONE AFTER BEING
ON HOLD FOR A FEW SECONDS.
NAMED PATRICK MCCONNEL.
HE WAS THE DIRECTOR OF
COMMUNICATIONS FOR VOGUE.
AND HE SAID MS. WINTOR
DEMANDS A RETRACTION.
OF WHAT, I ASKED.
SHE DEMANDS THAT YOU CALL THE POST
AND HAVE THEM PRINT A RETRACTION.
AND I SAID, THAT WOULD
IMPLY IT'S NOT TRUE.
I SAID IT IS TRUE.
AND THIS HAPPENED.
AND I KEEP A DIARY.
IT WAS SEPTEMBER 12TH.
THE METROPOLITAN FIDDLING.
I WAS ON THE FLOOR.
AND THE METROPOLITAN IS AN
OLD INDUSTRIAL BUILDING.
IT'S ONE BIG FREIGHT ELEVATOR.
AND MS. WINTOR WILL NOT RIDE
IN AN ELEVATOR AND ALONE
WITH HER SECURITY DETAIL.
SO WE WERE -- MY COLLEAGUES
AND I WERE GOING TO THE SHOW
AND SPECULATING NOT
HOW SHE WOULD ARRIVE,
THAT CAN BE EASY FACILITATED.
GET HER IN ALONE.
GET HER OUT.
BUT HOW SHE WOULD DESCEND.
BECAUSE IT'S A FRANTIC MAD RUSH.
YOU GOT TO LEAVE THAT LOCATION.
AND GET TO THE NEXT
LOCATION FOR THE NEXT SHOW.
SO WE WERE STANDING.
ALWAYS HAPPY TO STAND
AT A FASHION SHOW.
OR WE WERE DIRECTLY
OPPOSITE ANNA WINTOR
AND HAD TWO HUGE BODY
GUARDS INSIDE OF HER.
AND THOUGHT, WHAT IS GOING TO
HAPPEN WHEN THE LIGHTS COME ON.
WELL, WE RAN OUT BEHIND THEM.
AND THERE WAS A BIG
GIANT OPEN STAIRCASE.
AGAIN, A BIG INDUSTRIAL BUILDING.
AND THE TWO SECURITY PEOPLE
MADE A FIRE MAN'S LOCK.
AND SHE SAT IN IT.
AND THEY WOOSHED HER
DOWN THE STAIRS.
SO I RAN TO THE WINDOW, TO
SEE WHETHER THEY WOULD PUT HER
DOWN ON THE SIDEWALK
OR TAKE HER TO THE CAR.
THEY TOOK HER TO THE CAR.
DOWN 18TH STREET THEY WENT.
I DIDN'T SAY ANY OF THAT.
HAD IT IN MY DIARY,
ALL OF THE INFORMATION
THAT I GAVE WITH PATRICK MCCONNEL.
OH, DEAR, OH, DEAR, OH, DEAR.
SO GOOD DAY, PATRICK.
[LAUGHTER].
TUESDAY HE CALLS.
HE CALLS. AND HE SAID,
YOU'RE GOING TO LOVE THIS.
HE SAID, I'LL HAVE YOU KNOW MS.
WINTOR KNOWS HOW TO WORK A MANOLO.
WHAT? SHE COULD TAKE THOSE STAIRS.
LOOK, I KNOW MS. WINTOR
KNOWS HOW TO WORK A MANOLO.
IT WASN'T WHETHER SHE
CAN WALK DOWN THE STAIRS.
IT'S ABOUT SPEED.
THESE GUYS AND THEIR FLAT SECURITY
SHOES WERE BEING MUCH FASTER
THAN SHE WOULD HAVE EVER
GONE IN THE MANOLOS.
ONCE AGAIN, OH, DEAR.
OH, DEAR. SO THE FOLLOWING DAY,
HE CALLS AND HE SAYS ALL RIGHT.
WE HAVE TO GET THE LAWYERS INVOLVED.
AND I SAID, GOOD.
BECAUSE THIS MEANS WE
CAN'T TALK ANYMORE.
SO THEN, YOU'RE GOING TO
LOVE THIS PART EVEN MORE.
A COLLEAGUE OF MINE WHO I HAD AN
APPOINTMENT WITH IN MY OFFICE,
CAME AND LOOKED AT ME AND
SAID YOU LOOK HORRIBLE.
WHAT'S GOING ON?
AND SO I TOLD HIM THE STORY.
AND HE SAID, I WAS THERE.
I SAW IT. HE PICKED UP THE PHONE.
HE CALLED PATRICK AND
HE SAID IT'S SO AND SO.
AND HERE IS THE PART
THAT YOU WON'T BELIEVE.
I CAN'T SAY SO AND
SO'S NAME ANYMORE.
BECAUSE BY AN ATTORNEY, ANNA
WINTOR THREATENED HIS JOB
BECAUSE OF THIS ASSOCIATION WITH ME.
BUT ANYWAY, HE SAVED ME.
SO HE SAID, I WAS THERE.
I SAW IT. AND OF COURSES
THERE WERE PROBABLY 100 PEOPLE
WHO -- WELL PROBABLY NOT.
THERE WERE PROBABLY 50 OF US
GATHERED AROUND THE STAIRWELL.
BUT SHE INSTILLED SUCH
FEAR IN PEOPLE
THAT NO ONE WOULD SAY ANYTHING.
WELL YES, SHE DOES SCARE ME.
SO I DECIDED TO TAKE THE HIGH ROAD.
I CALLED THE FLOREST THAT I USED.
AND I SAID I WANT AN ENORMOUSLY
STAGGERING BEAUTIFUL ALL WHITE
ARRANGEMENT SENT TO MS. WINTOR.
AND I WROTE MY OWN NOTE.
TOOK IT TO THE FLORIST
TO ACCOMPANY THIS.
AND THOUGHT, OKAY.
THIS IS THE RIGHT THING TO DO.
HOWEVER, I HAD A SECRET EMBEDDED
MESSAGE IN THE WHITE FLOWERS.
HERE IN WESTERN CULTURE
IT MEANS PEACE.
BUT IN ASIAN CULTURES
IT MEANS DEATH.
[LAUGHTER].
GOT IT. HOW DID WE GET
OFF ON THIS TANGENT?
ANYWAY --
>> SPEAKER: I DON'T
THINK WE WILL TOP THAT.
>> SPEAKER: OH, THE GALA.
I WAS INVITED.
WHEN LIZ CLAIREBORNE, MY
BOSS OR CEO INVITED ME.
THE FIRST YEAR, YOU'RE
COMING WITH ME.
DON'T BE RIDICULOUS.
I BUY A TABLE EVERY YEAR.
AND COME WITH ME.
WITH HIS TAIL BETWEEN
HIS LEGS HE CAME TO ME
AND SAID SORRY YOU
HAVE BEEN UNINVITED.
AND SHE GOES THROUGH THAT LIST.
AND I DON'T WANT TO GO
TO THAT THING ANYWAY.
WHAT WAS YOUR SECOND QUESTION?
>> SPEAKER: WE HAVE
ONE LAST QUESTION.
AUDIENCE MEMBER: HI,
WOW, THAT'S LOUD.
WHAT WAS YOUR FAVORITE
CHALLENGE ON PROJECT RUNWAY?
>> SPEAKER: I HAVE TO SAY
IT'S VERY SENTIMENTAL FOR ME.
SEASON 1 CHALLENGE 1 WHEN WE HAD
TO GO TO THE HIGH END FABRIC STORE
AND WE TOOK THEM TO A GROCERY STORE.
AND WE SAID OKAY.
HERE IS YOUR MONEY.
SHOP FOR ALL OF THESE
UNCONVENTIONAL MATERIALS.
IT DOESN'T APPEAR IN THE SHOW.
BUT ONE OF MY FAVORITE MOMENTS
WITH AUSTIN SCARLET WHO WON
THAT CHALLENGE WITH THE
INCREDIBLE CORN HUSK DRESS.
IT WAS STAGGERING.
HE HAD A SHOPPING CART
FILLED WITH CORN.
AND ON TOP OF IT WERE ALL OF
THESE BAGS OF POTATO CHIPS.
I SAID, I UNDERSTAND THE CORN.
BUT WHAT ARE THE POTATO CHIPS FOR?
AND HE SAID FOR THE BUS RIDE HOME.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE].
ARE FABULOUS.
>> SPEAKER: THANK YOU.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE].
AUDIENCE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE].
>> This is been a presentation
of Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov.